good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to this last European Council
press conference after the October
summit I first invite the president of
the human comes not risk to take the
fall thank you good afternoon
last night the leaders discussed
enlargement the overwhelming majority
wanted to open accession talks with
North Macedonia and Albania however such
a decision requires unanimity and there
was no you know Amity esterday Letta
Friday you will revert to this issue
before the Zagreb summit in May 2020 let
me be very clear
North Macedonia and Albania are not to
blame for this and the Commission
reports also clear that both these
countries did what they were asked to do
and the adoption of the press back women
twas a truly extraordinary achievement
so both countries have the right to
start EU negotiations as of today they
already unfortunately a few member
states are not ready yet this is why we
didn't manage to reach a positive
decision personally I think it was a
mistake
but I will not comment on it further
today I would like to send a message to
our Macedonian and Albanian friends
please do not give up I fully understand
your frustration because you did your
share and we haven't the you is a
complex political entity and it is true
that sometimes it takes too long to
decide but I have absolutely no doubt
that one day you will become full
members of the European Union today
leaders also discussed the priorities of
the new commission with president-elect
from the layin as well as the future in
your budget it was an important
discussion that will continue in the
following months
however without jean-claude and myself
around the European Council table as you
know on this note I want to thank John
cloud my colleague and friend for our
friendship for your loyalty and
solidarity and for our really great
cooperation and I also want to thank you
the media for your tough but fair
questions for your patience for staying
up so late with us and for laughing at
some of our jokes no never funny frankly
speaking thank you thank you for
everything thank you and now president
of the European Commission we shall
denote metal Minister shares are me just
with red shoes you ready doc concluded a
bath lela lela rese ma hideous ankle you
know the funky remain video Parliament
Connelly Sangha dayavan eponymous ankeny
the moment in Europe due to the largest
mo Slovak okay
who could deception horizonte back on
she don't owe me inset of array if we
are more secure visible token data
nouveau token of Aleta
so they amendment predicted about the
veneer mo miss economy services they as
well
freedom to talk first in the search but
in the Saudi SEPA the deal see we know
that Macedonia know a lot bonier
template to cut rental in European it so
she said the DC we know he'll prove a
the veneer
only tonkin tada tech indeed avec la
nación commence a negotiation Rahman
save opiod don't say Maori to be a lady
Miriam a certain set imaginary person Co
said you looked ever historic you looked
at the historic disparity moment and a
pork Alison his father only Madonna
Madonna member collective commitment
este fin ever historic novel discrete a
also de la carte Ruffino ceadeus a tener
venir dare mo Nouveau you can say kids
available gasps yo de modo de consejo
pia to conquer happy demo sediba sinews
antonov hundred and a portion new pair
desert zone a canonical researcher nape
of departure a legend
no Papa Papa CP program eres muy loca
set in the prepare precede Divino
European the Cosa Nostra sue a dupe
answer applause
to arrive a nematode akka
Sylvia Commission apropos e+ Papa's jam
sesh he convened the politically few a
de novo politic Kiev
como si señora de consejo be the
Northmen top layer verification FET city
the small country team Canseco PA vocal
GRCC a very casual
approver deer killer assist a presence I
can't reconcile Peruvian Oh Madonna Mia
yeah
Donald personal media is a complicity
the leadership can observe a su coche de
ja vu de la mesa vu pasok vu
McComb panda PDF dot syrupy riyadh la
propiedad de ma vie de Pape interview
je suis via began today
Vasek he would report ash who's away
boozy aqua put the last permitted
develop the last refuges California v
tarp is heavier drop
thank you very much I now open the floor
for you are questions and we start over
here yes Michael
thank you Michael Peele Financial Times
Chancellor Merkel has said that under
the the brexit deal agreed that the UK
will be a third country and therefore a
rival is that also how you you see it
and secondly if I could ask you both a a
more personal question about how you see
your legacies and how optimistic you are
further the development of the Union
given that the challenges not just a
brexit but enlargement spoken about
there are clearly quite serious
divisions in the Union today that are
that will need to be overcome if it's to
be sustainable I think that mrs. Merkel
is right when she is saying that the UK
will become a third country I don't like
this perspective but that's the choice
of the British people as far as my
legacy is concerned I would be too long
to in to point out all the successes
which were mine
and adding defeats to the successes you
would be a tomorrow morning I think it's
not the best moment to talk about our
legacy for him it would be too too long
for me to brief you know it
[Laughter]
I agree totally with jean-claude this is
a very special day I should agree at
least today with you Thank You Ernest
Balu from your usual bin Albania you are
both leaving the you and apart from
being a mistake what happened yesterday
do you recognize also that this is a
failure when it comes up to the part of
the European Union in keeping up its
commitment and responsibilities thank
you as I mentioned in my in my
introduction you should never give up it
[Music]
you know I remember when I when was the
first time when I started to dream about
the European future for my country and I
think I was maybe 30 35 years old
guidance and and I had to wait more than
25 years for this you know it's mmm it's
not a failure it's a mistake
yeah I feel really embarrassed at and
it's not just to you know to
to help our tu-tu-tu-tu-tu defense the
Macedonian of Albanian government and
that's not it's a it's this is what I
really feel today after yesterday's
discussion that both country they passed
the exams and I can't say this about our
member states we see no hope Ian do it
respect not have a blue moon Gerald what
Anissa promise
thank you
next question Lawrence
thanks a lot Lawrence Norman of the Wall
Street Journal two questions if I may
first one first all on Turkey there was
a discussion last night we haven't heard
much about it publicly could you could
you fill us in and and is there a
feeling that the relationship with
Turkey
is at a turning point for the worst or
is this just another bump in the road in
a difficult relationship and and I just
like to ask president Erskine annulment
if you're wrong and if this is the
beginning of the end of enlargement in
Europe what are the consequences if this
is the end of the announcement will have
to face severe criticism because we were
encouraging those countries we were
helping those countries we were visiting
those countries and we were we were
making publicly promises to this
country's so I'm coming back to what I
said just a minute ago if we want to be
respected we have to keep our promises
yes thank you now I don't want to
escalate some emotions and to provoke
[Music]
new tensions between the EU and Turkey
the situation is quite obvious it's
so-called ceasefire this is not what we
expected in fact it's not a ceasefire at
the amount of capitulation of the Kurds
and I think that we have to be very
consistent here and we have to do to
raise the rate our call for Turkey to
put a permanent end to its military
action immediately and to withdraw its
forces and and respect international
humanitarian law and this is for sure
not the result of Vice President Spencer
and president Erdogan agreement when
comes to enlargement
today when it comes to enlargement and
the future of this process its you are
right it's very difficult to be
optimistic but there's no reason to say
that there's a total failure you know
because even if some member states are
still skeptical I have to underline
again that it was really overwhelming
majority ready to to accept this anyway
very difficult and challenging process I
mean this is accession talks with
Albania and Macedonia it's not easy for
all of us and this is why I think we
have to it's not it's not maybe the
easiest moment for us but I want to to
look at the bright side on this
yesterday's discussion you know 24 25
member states are determined to continue
this process it's ok our political
structure is very complex as you know
and sometimes we need unanimous decision
this is the problem but I have no doubts
that that this is Jeff Jeff and
short-time crisis not not not the end of
the story of enlargement and I have to
treat this this message that they are
ready to continue the discussion and to
to maybe to find a solution before May
2020 we have to treat it as a self
obligation of all no mistakes
thank you and mark
good afternoon mark paper corn for
school Netherlands it's regarding the
MFF
the aim of the discussion today was to
get some guidance from the heads of
state about the overall size the
distribution on the different chapters
did you get anywhere more near these
guidance and if not what will happen now
will because the aim was also to have a
decision in December I don't think that
will be decision in December I hope that
things will be moved in a way that we
can come closer to a decision it was in
fact the stock taking meeting because
everyone was repeating positions we
already knew so there is no new element
no guidance nothing thank you on that
positive note thank you all very much
for coming and I conclude the press
conference thank you okay